en quinchasa la visita de Manuel macron
genera expectativa cultura deporte
educación Ese es el programa oficial
pero para los habitantes de kingyaza es
imposible que el presidente francés no
aborde las cuestiones de seguridad
mientras el m-23 apoyado por Ruanda
según Naciones Unidas siga apoderándose
el territorio en el este del país
si hay una sanción de Francia Ruanda
será un acto fuerte y positivo para los
congoleños y ahí confirmaremos que
Francia está con nosotros y no apoya a
los agresores
una expectativa compartida por el
caricaturista Cash Bajo su trazo de
Lápiz el rostro de Manuel macron
tomaforma El objetivo denunciar las
relaciones entre Francia y Ruanda el
dibujante no duda en forzar la línea
para hacer reaccionar a la gente y la
ley de culinadizo la puerta de la
República democrática del Congo y antes
de volver duda porque tiene los pies
chorreando sangre y el hombrecito le
dice no te preocupes sabemos que duermes
en kigali evidentemente para marcar la
proximidad entre Francia y el régimen de
cagarme revisar las relaciones parece
una prioridad para Manuel macron los
congoleños parecen desconfiar cada vez
más de Francia así lo revela una
reciente encuesta de este centro de
investigación Francia ya no es un socio
privilegiado según los 3000 condolenas
encuestados frente a ella China y Rusia
ganan influencias
hay una decepción debido al hecho de que
en las anteriores crisis de los grandes
lagos desde el m-23 en las que la
República democrática del Congo se
enfrentó también a Ruanda Francia estuvo
muy claramente del lado congoleño por lo
que se produce Este cambio que sigue a
cierto resentimiento
[Música]
por lo tanto Este es el ambiente que
recibe Manuel macron en la República
democrática del Congo el país francófono
más grande del mundo